giving everybody boys from anywhere on
the planet now I don't even think it's
that hard to do we need to reach out as
caring citizens and to help get these
poverty victims wife's back on track
somehow remodeling the economic system
to take into account the environment
high school should have scholarships for
seniors leaving the school a vehicle
that runs on something other than
gasoline that can easily be sold around
the world for everyone access he cycled
pass it on to much of our resources go
into livestock production every year
roughly 60 million people starve to
death if America were to reduce its meat
intake by just ten percent those 60
million people could be adequately fed
first everybody of us spends one euro or
one dollar or whatever you're paying in
your country with for his government
second it must be forbidden by law for
elected politicians to work for any
corporations or to have any other jobs
beside if the government is paid
directly by us it might start to work
directly for us mom saying make solar
panels by the millions in India Europe
America Japan my solution the daughters
question is that governments around the
world take more action to read people of
their complacent mindsets and encourage
citizens dior you go freely by giving
away things like free exhaust pipe
filters and coupons on energy saving
bulbs in short we need to start teaching
people to stop relying on the person
next door save the world to accept and
cherish in a positive constructive
matter
the works of others
and to respect yourself but only doing
constructive things we can save
thousands if not millions of lives by
simply providing mosquito nets to
malaria ridden areas around the world we
should be putting money into researching
genetic engineering of plants so that we
can get more food out of every acre of
farmland make a website on which can be
good lectures or debates discussions
about all sorts of important subjects
like politics economics religion all
that kind of stuff if Central America
was to unite in a manner of cooperation
much like the European Union I believe
they could have a much better economic
growth and they could more evenly
distribute funds to where its most
desperately native the answer is simple
it's one word perspectival perspective
at no other time in history have the
countries of this world been more
empowered to promote education solutions
must be made through collaboration and
knowledge and that is how we should
change the world have an open mind about
everything and admit that you could be
wrong
you